madame la présidente madame la première
ministre chers collègues vous n'avez pas
dans cet hémicycle a semblé que vous
espériez votre formation politique et
vos alliés ne forment plus qu'une
majorité relative très relative cette
déroute d'un président de la république
privé de majorité absolue n'est pas un
accident de parcours elle est d'abord
l'expression du rejet massif de la
méthode de gouvernement qui a prévalu
sous le précédent quinquennat
l'hypertrophie
présidentielle a vécu le chef de l'état
ne peut donc affirmer que les français
lui ont renouvelé leur confiance sur le
fondement d'un projet clair et en lui
donnant une légitimité clair il n'a pas
de mandat pour imposer son agenda
politique
l'heure n'est plus à l'exercice
solitaire du pouvoir
l'heure n'est plus à l'arrogance et au
mépris des revendications populaires
elle n'est plus au passage en force à
l'humiliation du parlement aux pouvoirs
exorbitants des cabinets de conseil qui
considèrent les êtres humains comme des
agrégats statistiques et comme des
chiffres à gérer la démocratie enfin
retrouve des couleurs et vous allez
devoir apprendre à écouter à dialoguer à
respecter la représentation nationale
est adopté une attitude constructive
vous avez par ailleurs devant vous une
assemblée divisée à l'image de notre
pays que vous avez contribué à fracturer
tout en faisant grandir la peste brune
votre politique de défaisance sociale
conduite avec acharnement à attiser la
colère de nos concitoyens qui assiste à
l'effondrement de notre système de santé
au dépeçage dans le système éducatif au
recul des services publics à la
dégradation de l'environnement et de
leurs conditions de vie à présent il
ploie sous la hausse de l'inflation
tirés par les prix de l'énergie des
matières premières vous répondez comment
leurs difficultés en multipliant les
rustines en accumulant les petits
chèques et des mesures d'urgence
inefficace et sans lendemain comment
pourrait-il en être autrement car le
chef de l'état a fixé pour ligne rouge
de n'augmenter ni les impôts ni la dette
comme davos gouvernants l'immobilisme
des lanternes du quinquennat vous n'avez
les mains libres que pour reprendre
d'une main ce que vous donnez de l'autre
pour opérer des coupes sombres dans les
dépenses publiques et pour détricoter
notre système de protection sociale et
de retraite
nous n'acceptons pas cette politique du
pire qui conjugue injustices sociales
précarité inaction climatique recul des
services publics nous récusons
l'arbitraire de ces fameuses lignes
rouges nous avons une exigence
revoir de fond en comble notre système
fiscal pour garantir une meilleure
répartition des richesses et de la
valeur réduire les écarts de revenus
pénaliser la rente financière améliorée
significativement le niveau de vie de
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
mettre en oeuvre ce que préconise l abbé
pierre le contraire de la misère ce
n'est pas la richesse le compère de la
misère c'est le partage
nous devons aussi
remettra en cause des règles budgétaires
européennes pour recréer un état clé
planifient et investit dans la
transition écologique dans notre système
éducatif sacrifié dans la restauration
de notre système de soins dans l'extrême
dégradation tétanise notre peuple à
l'aube de cet été que tous les
professionnels de santé prédisent comme
dramatique à raison du manque de
personnel l'autre urgence est de
revaloriser de manière significative et
pérenne les salaires les pensions et les
minima sociaux mais aussi de bloquer le
prix des loyers des carburants de
l'énergie
de telles mesures
répondent non seulement une attente de
nos concitoyens mais une nécessité
économique
l'enjeu de favoriser l'accès de tous à
une alimentation il ya des biens plus
durable et de meilleure qualité
l'urgence est enfin en matière
internationale de promouvoir la paix
cela passe en europe par la résolution
des causes profondes du conflit
craignant nous ne créerons pas les
conditions d'une sécurité civile
collective européenne sans remettre en
cause la manière dont celle ci était
construite 100 euros désarmement sans
nous appuyer sur l'oeil nu et le respect
du droit international
la même exigence
la même exigence vaut pour le proche et
le moyen-orient et le conflit israélo
palestinien
nous le dirons jamais assez la france
doit jouer un rôle moteur au plan
diplomatique pour récuser les deux poids
deux mesures et ouvrait en toute
souveraineté à la coopération solidaire
des nations et des peuples
il nous a pas échappé par ailleurs que
le groupe j'ai l'honneur de présider est
celui qui accueille en son sein le plus
grand nombre de parlementaires
d'outre-mer des parlementaires
décidé à faire entendre leur voix une
voix singulière qui va vous falloir le
aussi apprendre à écouter respecter sur
ces territoires la situation est
gravissime se nourrir se loger se
soigner
se déplacer tout est déjà puces étaient
déjà plus cher avant la crise désormais
les shows coûts explosent au mono pour
les diots paul tracy sont lourdes
amendes s'ajoute le fret maritime dans
les tarifs ne semble plus avoir de
limites
aucun secteur n'est épargné les prix des
matières premières flambent les
consommateurs trinquent souvent cité
comme un exemple à suivre
le bouclier qualité prix de la réunion
qui limite les prix des produits de
première nécessité est lui même menacé
puisque des industriels locaux en
demande de révision davantage encore que
dans les autres territoires oubliés de
la république
nombreux sont nos citoyens d'outre-mer
qui survivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
l'inflation amplifiera ses ravages si
des mesures fortes ne sont pas prises
sans plus attendre la revalorisation du
coefficient géographique est devenue une
urgence et ne peut plus à nouveau être
reporté
dans ce contexte le développement des
circuits courts et l'objectif
d'autonomie alimentaire sont partout
partout préconisé mais aussi entravé
bien des terres antillaises sont
polluées pour des siècles par ce
scandale d'état de l'utilisation massive
de la peur des cônes
tandis tandis que le statut du foncier
en guyane a interdit tout développement
d'initiatives locales connaissez vous un
autre territoire de la république où 95%
du foie du foncier relève du patrimoine
de l'état ou un agriculteur où un
industriel
un maire est confronté un foncia bon
dans des rangs du rare est cher par cet
anachronisme
juridico-politique ces territoires ne
doivent plus être placé à la périphérie
c'est pourquoi nous continuerons à
porter aussi la voix du peuple
polynésien meurtri par les conséquences
des essais nucléaires français
je souhaite ici
je souhaite ici tordre le cou à un
réflexe tenace identifiant les outre-mer
à une dynamique de difficultés non
seulement ces territoires paie au prix
fort des politiques publiques souvent
inadaptée mais ils sont également au
coeur des nouveaux enjeux planétaires
dans ce 21e siècle à vocation maritime
la france peut se targuer d'être la
deuxième puissance maritime mondiale
longtemps négligé cette dimension
maritime est devenu central comme l'a
montré le récent sommet mondial pour
l'océan à lisbonne
de même en ce qui concerne l'enjeu vital
de la préservation d'un million
diversité la france tire sa force d
outre-mer qui représente 84 % de la
biodiversité française plus importante
plus importante que celle de toute
l'europe continentale
mais comment prendrez-vous en mieux en
compte ces difficultés réelles et ses
promesses tout aussi réel avec le retour
d'une configuration que nous avions
connu lorsque le ministère d outre-mer
placé sous tutelle de l'intérieur
avaient vu fondre ses effectifs
madame la première ministre votre refus
de soumettre votre déclaration de
politique générale au vote de la
représentation nationale traduit le
décalage de votre feuille de route avec
les attentes du pays vous considère
ainsi que votre gouvernement ne tire pas
sa légitimité sa légitimité de la
semaine nationale mais encore et
toujours du chef de l'état cela ne
présage rien de bon pour l'avenir
d'autres notre pays et c'est pourquoi
nous prendrons pour notre part
toutes nos responsabilités en faisant du
tome 1 au sein de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale
mais aussi mais c'est aussi comme groupe
indépendant force de proposition qui a
la culture du débat démocratique
je reprendrai pour terminer des mots
d'aimé césaire dans le combat de l'ombre
et de la lumière dans la lutte entre
l'espoir le désespoir entre la lucidité
la ferveur nous sommes du côté de
l'espérance mais comme aimé césaire le
digestive bien du côté d'une espérance
conquise le cid hors de toute naïveté
oui hors de toute naïveté aussi la
question à laquelle nous devons répondre
aujourd'hui d'abord
savoir quels chemins d'espérance est
tout vert par vos propos nous jugerons
sur pièce mais nous ne pouvons en douter
tant la servitude mercantile qui
étouffent notre république va étouffer
votre gouvernement comme le disait
jacques londons qui parlait du talon de
fer en ce qui nous concerne face au
renoncement comme au moins d'avancer
nous n'aurons qu'une boussole celle de
l'intérêt du peuple du franc du peuple
de france de ce peuple qui attend des
réponses à la hauteur de sa colère
[Applaudissements]